[موسيقى]
اخفاء وحفظ شيء الثمين عن الانظار يسمى
بالكنز والتمر الذي يوضع في مكان مخصص
والذي يسمى عند هلولين الله يرحمهم بل جثه
او صوبه او المنقوله يسمونه بالكنيز ليش
لانه كنز غذائي ثمين وخفاء الثريا او
الجوزه عن الانظار لدخولها في حمره شعاع
شمسي مع مغيب الشمس يسمى بالكنه هذا عندنا
واهل الخليج يسمونها بالخفوق فكان السماء
اخذت عقد الثريا والجوزه واخفتها عن
الانظار اذا الجوزاء يوما حلقت على
كواكبها كجمر
مو قديم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تختفي نجوم الجوزه عن
الانظار لدخولها في حمره شعاع شمسي مع
مغيبها وهي اماره وعلامه على بدايه فصل
الصيف والصيف له بدايه وشده ونهايه
فبدايته تسمى بالصيف وشدته تسمى بجمره
ونهايته تسمى بمرخيات القلائد والجوزه
ثلاثه نجوم وبغيابها نطلق الشتاء ثلاث
طلقات لا غابه الجوزه وبار رقيبها فلا صيف
الا صيف من العام
عايد
[موسيقى]